one of the observations that I've had
over the past two days is that other
Naville programs that I've attended have
been well-run and have built a a
permanent momentum of their own like the
bond attorneys workshop which is held
annually the Washington workshop this
year joins that group of programs that
now has a momentum of its own with more
than 300 attendees and numerous
workshops and general sessions with
major speakers from the government and
that effort really is due to the work of
the chairman of this this workshop Bob
buck and yesterday bob was very
complimentary to everybody that had
worked on the workshop but the entire
effort really this year in terms of the
organization and the staffing of the
workshop was Bob's job and
responsibilities and he he did it very
well with the assistance of Amy Dunbar
and I'm Rita Carlson and I like
everybody to to join me to this morning
in thanking Bob
okay Kate Maguire our speaker this
morning I'm having as much trouble with
this light as Elliot did yesterday cape
Maguire speaker this morning is special
assistant to the director of the
division of market regulation at the
Securities and Exchange Commission the
division is responsible for the
regulation of brokers and dealers and
oversight of the securities market Kate
carries out a variety of special
projects particularly those involved in
coordination with the Congress other
government agencies and other offices
and divisions within the Commission her
recent projects have included the
development of the the interpretive
release and proposed rule 15c 2-12
concerning municipal securities
disclosure which chairman Reuters spoke
about yesterday assisting the chairman
in preparing his October 1987 speech to
the public securities Association and
because of the timing of that speech
actually delivering the speech which
gave Kate an opportunity not only to to
write it but also to be responsible for
the wards and those of us that were were
there that really marked the beginning
of the disclosure debate this time
around drafting and implementing the
government Securities Act of 1986
participating in various commissioned
legislative initiatives concerning the
separation of banking and brokerage and
advising the division generally advising
the division of corporate finance in
connection with its rulemaking
initiatives on prospectus delivery for
corporate securities kate has been with
the Securities and Exchange Commission
since her graduation from the University
of Kansas Law School in 1973 she has
held positions of increasing
responsibilities including counsel to
Commission of Bevis long strength an
assistant director in the device
of market regulation from my perspective
one of the best things about dealing
with Kaede is that she provides an
institutional memory in the disclosure
area in municipal finance having worked
in the area since the mid 1970s she has
had responsibility for a variety of
projects in the municipal area including
the implementation of the Securities Act
Amendments of 1975 establishing the msrb
and requiring registration of Municipal
Securities Dealers oversight of the msrb
from 1975 to 1980 and participation in
drafting both the municipal securities
full disclosure Act of 1978 and the
Commission's final report on New York
City when I first heard Kate McGuire say
some time ago
I'm from the federal government and I'm
here to help you I was naturally
skeptical all too often state and local
officials bond counsel and others
involved in municipal bonds have been
disappointed in our dealings with people
in Washington however as dean Polk noted
yesterday in his introduction of
Chairman ruder the process on the
development of the SEC guidelines turned
out to be substantially different we did
not always agree with the SEC nor
unfortunately did they always agree with
us nor did they draft a perfect proposed
rule but thanks to Kate and the staff at
the SEC the industry received a proposed
rule to comment on which formed a sound
basis for intelligent thoughtful
comments by all concerned groups and
individuals in view of the initial
drafting process I am confident that
Kate and the rest of the staff at the
Commission will carefully consider all
of the comments received will ask
questions about them and will ultimately
publish a rule that will not adversely
affect the municipal bond industry
is there for my pleasure at this time to
introduce Kate McGuire good morning this
is the first time I've ever been asked
to speak to a group to begin speaking
before 9:00 in the morning as I was
looking for a glass of orange juice this
morning I overheard a sort of an instant
review of one of yesterday's speakers
not much new no jokes this has made me a
little nervous although I have a brand
new text and I probably will have to
read a lot because of that I skip the
joke frankly I've always thought the SEC
disclaimer was an opening joke
furthermore with the FCC's budget
problems I don't know if you're aware of
it but we received slightly less than
the military bands we don't have the
resources to develop much in the way of
good material as a matter of fact the
SEC as a whole has only three jokes I
know I know you've heard them all so
I'll just hit the highlights what's the
biggest lie I'm from the government I'm
here to help how does a lawyer make it
through shark-infested waters
professional courtesy
what's the world's oldest profession
economists in the beginning there was
chaos they created it but seriously
thank you for inviting me to speak to
you today I believe this program may
have the greatest concentration of SEC
speakers on a single subject that has
ever been assembled of course each of us
will speak only for ourselves not for
the Commission the commissioners or the
staff of the Commission Chairman ruder
has already outlined for you the basics
of what we have proposed and how we got
there
Bob Colby and Eadie Pittman will be
participating in workshops today to
answer or possibly nimbly avoid
answering the tough questions you've
brought about the Commission's in this
tips I will try to provide a summary of
the feedback that we have received first
let me compliment you on the thorough
and persuasive letter that has been
submitted on your behalf as as Nabal it
was prepared by your special disclosure
committee which was chaired by Paul
Maiko and I believe that he and the
entire committee deserve your thanks and
if you want to give it to them now I'm
willing to leave the applause I have
read every comment letter but I haven't
mastered them all accordingly I hope
you'll forgive me if I don't mention
your key concern also I have a special
note for the press even at the staff
level
surprisingly the introduction to the
release and the rule received
substantial comment some commenters
suggested that because detailed default
data was included it was particularly
relevant to the Commission's proposals
and the Chairman emphasized the degree
to which he considered defaults
yesterday in his speech nevertheless I'd
like to point out to you that the
release itself suggests that the purpose
of the proposals is to improve the
accuracy and timeliness of disclosure
upon which investors rely other
commenters suggested that to greater
emphasis was given to the New York City
and whoops problems when conduit
financing have had greater default rates
commenters on the rule itself focused
particularly on the scope of the
proposed rule whether it should be
applied to all distributions of
municipal securities or only to initial
offerings or only to initial public
offerings commenters also expressed
opinions on eliminating lowering or
raising the ten million dollar threshold
in the rule most commenters argued that
the rule should not distinguish between
types of securities although there was
substantial opinion to the contrary to
the extent one type was singled out it
most often was conduit securities with a
suggestion for greater regulation of
offerings of those securities short-term
securities were also singled out most
often for exclusion from the rule
although other commenters suggested that
an exception for limited offerings to
institutional purchasers or some other
private offering exemption might better
address the types of short-term maturity
securities for which the rule was most
likely to impose unwarranted costs that
is variable rate demand notes and
municipal commercial paper while some
commenters suggested that an
institutional deal could be adequately
identified by limiting the denominations
in which the bonds were issued or the
size of positions that could be taken
for book entry securities others
suggested additional safeguards or
requirements such as the requirement
that an underwriter not know that the
purchaser
intended to resell the securities
several pointed out that parallels to
the 1933 Act might be unworkable given
state law publication requirements and
others pointed out that exceptions that
too closely paralleled the 33 act would
undercut what most argued was one of the
best features of the rule and proposal
that is its avoidance of 33 act
standards this was not a universal theme
however other commenters suggested that
virtually every 1933 act exception
should have a parallel in this
rulemaking and there was a reasonable
degree of sentiment for an intrastate
exemption the first requirement of the
proposed rule is the requirement that
underwriters obtain and review a
virtually final official statement prior
to bidding for purchasing a new issue of
securities the key policy concern with
this requirement was the fact that it
did not allow for a commitment to be
made subject to receipt of acceptable
information that is wire deals there was
also some difficulty in interpreting
whether this was a requirement for a
preliminary official statement in which
case some commenters argued much more as
customarily left out and currently the
preliminary official statement is
discretionary or whether it required
that a new document be produced in which
case many argued it was burdensome my
answer to this confusion is that for
those deals of which we have been told
there are many where there are no
differences between the POS and the
final OS the rural reverse refers to the
preliminary for the many deals where the
POS is not complete the rule is not
referring to the POS but to a final OS
that admits only information specified
in the proposed rule that's our proposal
for those who interpreted the rule in
this way there were particular
suggestions that credit enhancements and
information about a credit enhancer be
included in the category of information
that can be omitted as well as ratings
and information response to rating
agency comments information included in
response to underwriter comments
information concerning events sub
but to the time when the virtually final
OS is submitted to the underwriter and
other changes from the OS that are not
Material or that our material and would
improve disclosure lots of suggestions
given the breadth of these suggestions
some suggested that the standard be
reformulated to require something like
an OS that is materially complete at the
time of the bid or agreement to purchase
commenters also suggested various
phrases to make clear that the issuer's
opinion as to whether the document met
the standards of the rule at this stage
that is at the nearly final OS stage was
more relevant than than the opinion of
the underwriter in that connection
commenters suggested that the rule
recognized that for conduit securities
the relevant issuer may be the corporate
obligor not the governmental issuer the
second requirement of the proposed rule
is the requirement to deliver a
preliminary official statement to any
person on request there were comments
suggesting that any such requirement be
limited to potential investors and
suggestions that the term be defined to
include customers of the dealer and
other persons solicited by the dealer
there also were suggestions that more of
a definition of POS was needed than the
reference in the rule to a document
produced by the issuer for dissemination
to potential bidders and purchasers
there was substantial concern as to how
the rule would apply particularly in
competitive offerings where issuers do
not always supply sufficient copies of
the POS to potential underwriters for
distribution but instead take
responsibility for distribution
themselves they suggested that the rule
would be it would inappropriately shift
this burden from issuers to underwriters
particularly in competitive deals it was
not clear when potential underwriters
would assume the duty to provide the
documents my best answer under the terms
of their proposed rule as drafted and I
acknowledge that it is unclear is that
the obligation would begin when the
prospective underwriters received the
POS
there were also concerns that
underwriters would have a duty to
supplement the POS if it was not
accurate some suggested that concern
about the quality of disclosure in a POS
should be a reason not to forward a copy
on request others suggested safe harbors
under the anti-fraud provisions for
compliance with this requirement of the
rule or that the requirement expire upon
deposit of a POS with a central
repository no one suggested that the
rule be revised to require the
underwriter to forward any request for a
POS to the issuer yet overall the
underlying concern appeared to be that
for some offerings particularly I think
competitive offerings of big issuers who
do a lot of offerings we had directed
the requirement to the wrong participant
in the distribution process the third
requirement of the proposed rule was
that the underwriter contract with the
issuer or its agent to receive within 2
business days of the bid or agreement to
purchase a sufficient quantity of final
official statements to meet the
requirements of this rule and the rules
of the msrb some suggested that rather
than count forward from the bid or
purchase agreement the rule should
require the contract to specify that
final os's will be provided a number of
days prior to settlement with the issuer
so that it can accompany the customers
money confirmation concern was expressed
particularly by lawyers that events
could occur between the completion of
the final OS and settlement that would
require supplementation amendment or
recirculation everyone said that two
business days wasn't long enough five
seemed to be the most common suggestion
furthermore there were calls for
recognition that a POS could be
supplemented and serve as a final OS and
that a final OS need not be a single
booklet but could instead be a
collection of documents and references
to publicly available documents the
Commission has avoided specifying the
content of an official statement
but commenters expressed concern that
the rules concerning delivery might
adversely affect the evolution of the
form of an official statement the PSA
commented that the GFO a through its
guidelines was the appropriate
organization to design less burdensome
official statements that is consistent
with the recognition given to the GFO a
in this area by the Commission and the
msrb the 4th provision of the proposed
rule would require underwriters to make
available a final official statement to
any person on request commenters
suggested that such a requirement apply
only to potential investors expire after
a reasonable time and include a safe
harbor for providing dated material
pursuant to the rule most commenters
suggested that this function would be
done best by a central repository there
were also comments on the definitions
but except to the extent that I've
already touched on them they were too
detailed for me to keep you here finally
there was some adverse comment on the
notion of having any sort of
prescriptive rule some suggested that
the Commission developed voluntary safe
harbor rules that traded away liability
under the anti-fraud provisions for
providing particular disclosure at
particular times others suggested that
pressure from underwriters newly alerted
to their responsibilities by the
Commission's interpretation coupled with
the more active consideration of the
central repository supplemented by
market forces and vigorous enforcement
of msrb rule g32
would address the concerns underlined
the proposed rule while in theory that
may be true I think that it is an
overreaction to a perceived need for
more flexibility in the rule it is
probably more economical for the
Commission to create that flexibility
than to launch an enforcement program
which would motivate underwriters to
comply with the interpretation and
sorry rule g32 to the interpretation
which stated that an underwriter must
have a reasonable basis for recommending
securities it under writes and provides
comfort that for a normal competitive
bid offering such a basis could be
formed based on a confessional review of
the issuers disclosure document there
were a variety of comments at least one
commenter argued there was no basis for
suggesting that underwriters had such
duties under the anti-fraud provisions
while another suggested that there was
no basis for making any distinction
between negotiated and competitive bid
offerings some found our tradition of
dealing with the most sensitive issues
and footnotes to be distracting for
example they thought it would be better
to say in text that the interpretation
did not establish an objective standard
of recklessness and that for each
particular offering there would be
relevant factors that were not set forth
in the interpretation clarification was
requested on the treatment of credit
enhancements credit enhancers and
investors argued that a credit
enhancement should not affect the degree
of disclosure concerning the underlying
credit others suggested that in some
cases it would be possible to have no
disclosure about the underlying credit
at all many called for the Commission to
recognize and discuss the duties of
other participants in the process
particularly issuers but with respect to
financial advisers where the Commission
had done that there was concern that the
Commission give greater consideration to
the variety of services performed by
financial advisers and their role as
agents of the issuer furthermore there
were requests for clarification or
possibly rollbacks
of the Commission's statements that in
connection with competitive bid
offerings underwriters should assess the
completeness of the disclosure for
example are there audited financial
statements concern was also expressed
that because of its frequent reference
to the official statement the
interpretation implied that there was no
other way for underwriters to meet their
reasonable basis obligation
finally there were suggestions that
appropriate record-keeping requirements
be developed to allow examiner's to
ascertain the underwriters are in fact
carrying out the review necessary to
form a reasonable basis the third major
component of the Commission's initiative
was solicitation of comments on the MS
Arby's proposal for a central repository
my favorite comment on this was from
Dean Pope your past president he said
the much-discussed idea of a central
repository is much like the idea of a
balanced federal budget
everyone recognizes the need for it
everyone is theoretically in favor of it
but there is widespread disagreement as
to how to achieve it and who should get
stuck with the cost I would also add
that everyone is willing to go to a
meeting on it beyond that there appears
to be a variety of ideas committee do
not want the SEC or the msrb to have too
great an involvement in such an effort
other strongly urged need for one or
both to mandate participation establish
standards or oversee or even carry out
operations somebody really wanted the
SEC to do it there are suggestions for
full text and summary only respond
repositories some underwriters believe
issuers should submit the official
statement everyone else believes
underwriters should submit the official
state most agree that what would be most
useful is to have issuers submit
periodic reports but few recommended
that that be required
there are also strong calls for
competition and some who see a central
repository as a natural monopoly I find
myself turning to the popular culture
for answers I think the Commission has
three choices Nancy Reagan's motto just
say no the Nike commercial just do it
and my personal favorite don't worry be
happy
thank you are there any questions
okay Thank You Kate for the thorough
analysis of the of the comments that
that were received and for some
indication of where it's going I think
those of us here would would like very
much not to worry and to be happy the
next part of the program are the
workshops which begin at 9:45 in the in
the breakout rooms thank you very much
and thank you for your attendance at the
workshop